[Musique]
en 2003 c'était avant l'explosion
d'internet si vous souvenez du commerce
sur internet j'ai écrit les hypermarchés
les grands hypermarchés de plus de 10
mille mètres carrés c'est fini
aujourd'hui vous le constatez et vous
lisez dans la presse en 2006 une grande
entreprise française a dit j'ai cinq
marques
j'ai 5 méga usine j'ai écrit s'il ya des
méga usine il y aurait des micros usine
dix ans après la principale marque de
cette entreprise était attaqué par des
micros usines et des micros marque en
juillet 2019
il a fait plus de 38 32 degrés encore
edge on corrige en alaska
j'ai écrit si on est dans ces conditions
là il va y avoir 20 millions de
kilomètres carrés au nord de
l'hémisphère nord qui vont se libérer
l'équivalent des états unis et de la
chine
nous sommes en 2040 maintenant on est en
il y à 200 millions d'habitants qui
habite au nord de l'hémisphère nord quel
est mon métier je suis prospectiviste ça
veut dire quoi
cela veut dire aider les entreprises à
imaginer le futur et voyez je vous ai
donné des exemples où le futur étonne un
peu pourquoi parce que l'hypermarché
on n'a pas toujours deux heures pour
aller acheter une boîte de petits pois
la grande marque
on aime bien le petit producteur celui à
côté de chez nous qui va nous faire des
petits produits sympas on connaît et
sait on connaîtra sa tête et il
va innover le nord de l'hémisphère nord
mais cette nouvelles terres à conquérir
donc vous voyez il n'y a pas forcément
de logique entre que ce que l'on voit et
ce qui se passe je rajoute juste une
chose il ya cent ans son temps à peu
près on finissait la guerre de cent ans
ça car se sentant de la guerre 14 18 il
ya eu c'est logique il ya eu plus de 18
millions mort en 18 19
il y a eu la grippe espagnole 30
millions de morts c'est à dire qu en
rentrant dans les années 20 on avait 50
millions de morts sur terre un terrien
sur 20 étaient morts un terrien sur 20
c'est comme si aujourd'hui il y avait
200 millions de morts on avait le moral
dans les chaussettes
et qu'est ce qui se passe au début des
années 20 on développe l'automobile on
développe l'avion développe la radio on
développe le jazz on développe de la
nouvelle architecture une nouvelle
peinture on développe une nouvelle
culture de la psycho de la psychologie
de la psychiatrie et cetera
ce sont les années folles il n'y a pas
de logique là dedans apparente une
chouette c'est un animal qui voit la
nuit qui voit l'invisible et j'ai eu ce
prix le prix la chouette de prix
l'intelligence économique pour la
méthode dont je vais vous parler les
signaux faibles
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un signal faible
c'est un fait paradoxal qui inspire
réflexion paradoxal c'est à dire contre
la pensée commune contre la pensée
établi contre la manière de penser en
silo lorsque
l'hypermarché chute quel est le signal
faible c'est qu'en réalité on a changé
de thermomètre ce qui est important
c'est le temps 20% des consommateurs
n'ont pas le temps de dépenser 2 heures
il faut qu'ils aillent vite donc on
n'est pas sur le critère prix unique sur
le critère temps la grande marque
la grande marque c'est comme une grande
pierre plus un mur est construit la vie
des grosses pierres plus y ait des
places pour des petites pierres et les
nains d'aujourd'hui sont peut-être les
géants de demain
regardez les gaffes à regarder google
qui a 21 ou 22 ans le nord de
l'hémisphère nord
mais bon sang c'est extraordinaire c'est
le nouveau monde
c'est le far west c'est le far north et
puisque nous dit aujourd'hui qu'on
habite dans des villes polluées une
terre qui est aussi polluée et là haut
on peut tout recréer
vous voyez on n'est pas dans la logique
que l'on pense
c'est là où est le secret du signal
faible et ce qui est intéressant c'est
de le trouver
alors comment on trouve et je vais vous
donner un mot un mot secret qui doit
rester entre nous qui est un peu
difficile à prononcer cure cris créé
vous avez répété avec après moi un deux
trois cures cris craie tout le monde
dort on recommence un deux trois cures
creek rêve ça va mieux
cure pour curiosité la curiosité c'est
sortir de sa zone de confort
c'est parler à son adversaire
c'est changer de journal changer de café
et changer de trajet rompre dans nos
habitudes c'est important cris c'est la
critique connaissez tous lorsque le sage
montre la lune l'idiot regarde le doigt
nous dit ça mais est ce qu'on sait
que c'est lui le sage et on se crée
c'est que lui et l'idiot et pourquoi
serait pas lundi
lundi six pour presser pas le contraire
par exemple on peut critiquer ce qu'on
nous reçoit et on reçoit beaucoup de
choses dans un temps ça vaut la peine
créé pour création chez sur un tapis
rouge peut-être bleus et pourrait être
vert il faut changer notre regard des
portails carrés où le dead wrong soyez
homme soyez femmes soyez petit soyez
grand soyez gros soyez chinois soyez
mexicain changer de regard et vous
verrez que la créativité va venir
c'est quelque chose d'extraordinaire de
changer ses habitudes et udo changer de
regard et bien c'est ça le mystère des
signaux faibles qui va vous amener les
signaux faibles et chose qui change
totalement
une dernière chose comme il disait je
sois mountain penser l'impensable
pensait impossible
penser le haïssable penser le haïssable
vous allez tout à coup trouvé un signal
faible tout petit tout invisible bien
cachés qui vous dit oui une idée là
c'est intéressant il faut le creuser
on peut y aller et n'oubliez pas une
chose c'est la plus grande crainte de
d'une entreprise c'est d'être surpris
alors surprenez là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]